so words are funny things
until they're not
so let me ask you about
what i think is one of the most powerful
and controversial words in the english
language the n word
so this is a word that i
can't say
that only certain people have the right
to say
i have a friend joe rogan
yeah who has
um
what would you say there was mass
pushback or highlighting of of the fact
that he
didn't just say n word but the said the
full word many times
throughout his conversations when
referring to
um
in a meta way
about the power of words
especially when related to certain
comedians using those words
um yeah
what do you think about this word
is it
empowering is it destructive
what is it what does it mean for
race in america
um what does it mean that people like
joe rogan
were
essentially
there's an attack to cancel
him for using the word
just as a scholar of human nature what
do you think about this whole thing
this is a phenomenon that interests me
okay
the n-word
[ __ ] i can say it because i'm black
but i mean i can also say it because i
like hip-hop
and when i listen to hip-hop i hear the
word all the time these [ __ ] they did
you know
watch out for these you know etc
uh i heard the word constantly as i was
growing up as a boy and a young man in
chicago [ __ ] ain't [ __ ]
that was said
that was you know
the the and that could be a reflection
of some kind of
pathology within the african-american
community of self-hatred and so forth it
could be or it could just be a
colloquial
linguistic way i mean i assume other
groups also have uh their
various i don't know how the irish talk
about their irish brothers and you know
whatever and um i i don't know how the
jews talk about the jewish brothers and
whatever
but black people when talking about
other black people use the n-word
all the time
my [ __ ] yeah n-i-g-g-a
yeah you know my [ __ ]
uh that is a term of endearment
my friend randall kennedy
uh the law professor at harvard
university has a book called [ __ ]
and he uses the word in the title of the
book the history of a strange history of
a
of a provocative word it's something
that there's a subtitle but the title of
the book
is n-i-g-g-e-r
colon
and then
he has a subtitle
um
i think
of course
the use of the word as a slur and an
insult
which is a
part of the history
of black people in the united states the
use of the word by the southern racist
segregationist we don't want no [ __ ]
up in here y'all you know [ __ ] [ __ ]
have no place in my restaurant in my
store etc
that's meant to be an insult it's an
insult to people it's a fighting word
it's a way that you say that to somebody
it's a it's a invitation for conflict
that said
what is it that about this particular
word and also the asymmetry of it
that do you think it's empowering to the
black community
to own a word
my honest answer to you is i don't know
i don't fully understand it
it has become symbolic in a way
and the policing of the use of the word
i can say it but white people can't say
it i can say it i'm not a racist i'm not
a self-hating black
you know i'm just speaking the language
of colloquial english
that has emerged amongst african
americans in which that word plays a big
role
but the prohibition on its use by others
and of course in the joe rogan case
it wasn't as if he was calling anybody
an n-word
he was simply pointing out
that people had said stuff in which the
n-word was a part of what they said
now he did make this statement about uh
uh how did he put in the planet of the
apes that one of the
offensive things that he said had you
know he walked into a room there's a
bunch of black guys standing around he
says like planet of the apes
he said it's like africa planet of the
apes yeah he should have it and he
should have been a little bit more
careful that was that was an insult
that was that was you know
something that uh
you know if you say that and people are
offended they have a right to be
offended and if you didn't mean to
offend him you can apologize and he did
apologize i accept his apology joe's
okay with me as far as that goes
um in fact uh mcwhorter and i john
mcwhorter and i at the podcast that i do
the glenn show i had a conversation part
of which touched on the joe rogan
phenomenon and we concluded he didn't
really do anything wrong i mean i mean
you can like her remember you can hate
him or whatever but the idea that he's a
racist is kind of ridiculous so frankly
i mean
you know uh if that's your test of what
constitutes a racist the utterance of
the word
uh then you know
it's kind of a it's it's kind of silly
as far as i'm concerned
you